Our next guest, Jean,
she just turned 50 and wanted to try
jumping out of a plane for the very first time.
And I actually have experienced jumping from a plane.
I went skydiving with my BFF.
Okay, I'm not dropping names.
It just happens to be Cameron Diaz
but no one told me how it was really going to feel.
So I called Jean up to offer her some advice
that I wish someone had told me.
And I was with her every step of the way.
Take a look.
I get to go skydiving today and jump out of a plane.
I am extremely thrilled and excited, and I won't lie.
I'm a little bit scared at the same time.
I'm skydiving, baby! (cheers)
Awesome!
Yes!
Oh my God!
Hi, Jean!
I'm so excited for you.
What inspired you to do this?
I just turned 50 last month in September,
and I am an adventurous person by heart.
And so this was just the perfect way for me
to kick off a new decade, being 50,
jumping out of planes, skydiving.
So my husband doesn't know, but I think when I'm 60,
I might do bungee jumping.
Can I tell you something?
Go for it.
I want you to get straight to the point.
No one told me this.
Have you ever put your mouth over a leaf blower?
I don't think I have, why?
You're about to.
One thing no one tells you about skydiving is
take a very big breath right before you jump out,
because I didn't,
and the wind, you literally are going to feel like this.
(screams)
Is your husband there with you?
Yes he is.
And he's so excited.
Oh!
Hi, Drew.
This is my husband.
Nice to meet you.
I noticed you're not in a suit.
No, I'm not.
(Jean laughs)
Now, why aren't you going today?
I think it was just trying to coordinate
coming up here.
She's trying to say you can't, you should go today.
She's saying I can go.
Oh my God!
I think I'm gonna jump today.
Seriously?
Seriously, this is happening?
(Jean laughs)
Yes!
I think I'm so excited for you guys.
I think it'll be so much fun.
Mike, have you ever put your mouth over a leaf blower?
(Jean laughs)
(intense music)
(awed music)
(Jean cheers)
I cannot even describe the feeling.
It was incredible.
Woo!
Oh my God!
I was like, is he okay? I don't see him.
That was awesome.
(audience applauds)
Yeah!
Yeah, I love it!
Now they're joining us!
After their very first time skydiving is Jean and Mike!
(audience cheers)
Hi, guys!
Hi, Drew!
Hi.
Hi, how are you?
I loved watching your video so much.
I mean, you see, like, the wind force that I'm speaking of.
Yes.
Thoughts, feelings?
Well, I actually took your advice
and took a deep breath before I jumped out of the plane.
And for the rest of my ride, I tried to concentrate
on my breathing, which really actually helped.
As you can see I'm trying to smile and breathe,
and my face was shaking.
It was just an incredible thrilling experience.
Oh, I'm so glad that you had a positive experience,
and that you could breathe!
Because I was literally like,
I'm going to die from not taking a breath for two minutes.
I didn't, I was like,
I haven't checked how long I can hold my breath.
That's awesome.
And now I need to know in the most serious situation.
Mike, what was it like for you now?
It was a thrill.
Thrill of a lifetime.
Now, can I ask what your ride home was like?
Because I swear, I'm not name dropping.
It's just sort of,
I just don't have a lot of famous friends.
I grew up in Hollywood, but I made best friends
with like Cameron Diaz when we were like 14 and 16,
like, we've known each other forever.
So, people happen to know her name,
but she's just my friend,
like, one of my best friends, my sister,
and we went skydiving together,
and that ride home, we felt really invincible.
I'm not going to lie.
How did you feel on the ride home?
I'd have to agree with that.
We felt like after that, we could probably do anything.
And my son was really bummed
that he wasn't able to do it with us.
So, we get to experience it again, I think.
Probably next year sometime, with him.
Oh, I love that.
Oh, how old is your son by the way?
17.
Oh, perfect.
Yeah, he's fearless.
He's had a lot of adventures with us, so.
Yeah.
Well, I love that you guys are so adventurous and I love
that you guys got to share this because I remember we, like,
I had my, like, feet outside the car window
and I was just like, kicking back and I felt
super immortal, super invincible.
And like, I could face anything.
Like I just conquered Everest after skydiving.
Yeah, we were just like, did we just do this?
Do we just jump out of a plane?
It was just such a surreal experience.
Something that we will always remember
for the rest of our lives.
Absolutely.
A story to tell our grandkids,
hopefully not too soon in the future, but someday,
we will be able to tell our grandkids about this.
Well, hope you had a hot make-out
because that is some serious,
like, aphrodisiac, foreplay, skydiving.
I'm just saying, you're like,
"Oh my God, we can do anything!"
Very exciting.
Well, I really loved getting to be a part of your journey.
And I just had this one life experience
with my girlfriend and I've really not gotten to revisit it,
or share it, or relive it.
And thanks to you, Jean and Mike, I feel like
I got to be a part of your journey
and go back in time to a moment that I will never forget.
If it's something you do once, it lives with you forever.
Absolutely. Absolutely.
Yeah.
And thank you for allowing us to share our experience
and having us on your show.
It was definitely something we won't forget
for the rest of our lives.
Thrill of a lifetime.
Oh, Jean and Mike, thank you
for saying that so much!
It's been so much fun getting to know you
and I love watching you jump out of a plane,
and I really want to welcome you guys to the skydivers club.
So, I had these custom skydiving suits made for you,
with your names on the back.
That's awesome.
Oh, that's so cool!
Look at that!
I love that, like, both the left arms are red.
That's kind of an interesting detail.
(Mike and Jean laugh)
But did you ever for one second think,
why am I defying death?
Oh, many times, of course.
But that's what it's about.
When you're adventurous,
and you've done previous things that,
when your adrenaline is pumping, yeah, of course.
But I will not regret this,
and hopefully I'll get to do it again soon.
We have to now.
Yeah! (laughs)
Yeah, we have our own custom suits.
We have to, now.
By the way, now we need to make one for your son.
And we want to thank our friends in Philly
at Skydive Philadelphia for coordinating this jump
and making this dream come true.
Gina, Mike, thank you for letting us tag along,
and thank you so much for being on the show.
You guys, this was so fun.
Oh.
For us too, absolutely.
Absolutely, the pleasure was ours.
Thank you.
(upbeat music)